somehow it held you back absolutely
cause i wasn't doing the [ __ ] that i
wanted to do
and just i feel like
you know
one thing about it every artist know
what's best for them
that's the thing that's what labels
managers my [ __ ] pr everybody gotta
understand that about artists we know
what's best for us we know what we want
we know what worked for us we pay
attention to ourselves more than anybody
do so you gotta think we're dealing with
a major you basically going to a
[ __ ] who from the outside
looking in and like all right you should
do this you should you know what i mean
it's like telling somebody that's like
somebody who didn't raise you telling
you what's best for you as a adult
like you got to where you were
by doing something and it's almost like
once you then you then you get on board
with a major and then they wanna they're
asking you to stop doing what got you
there and logically it don't make sense
because like what i've been doing
obviously got y'all
interested
in the we stop doing what got you all
attention it'll make sense you know what
i mean i feel like the labels should
just give input pay for the [ __ ] they
need to pay for and do the bigger level
[ __ ]
and let us let you run let us run let us
handle our music and the way we want to
market ourselves those [ __ ]
ain't doing no dumb [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying that's all that matters